Nothing like an extra week to rehab!
Light reps for the normal players, meditation
for Tom's cult
OK, thanks. Here's my special mind power
Toooom
Mariota to Mariota! And the Tennessee
Mariotas win!
Hey guys, am I good now?
Sure, I mean yeah, I think so
You're definitely better than...
AHHHH! AHHHH!
Look at this f--king guy!
We don't have a f--king quarterback!
What the f--k are we going to do?
Nicholas, come closer. There's one thing I need
you to do for me
You need me to win the Super Bowl?
No, just hand the ball off and try not
to lose points
Whiff!
How are you missing?
Nick! You scored seven TDs once
I think I used up all my touchdowns that game
OK, let's do some, uhh, footwork
All right, catch the bird!
We can always start Nate Sudfeld
He did score zero points last game
UGH!
Keep going Nick!
Uhh, Nick! Go up the stairs!
Like in the movie!
FOLESADELPHIA!
Yo, this was supposed to be our year
you know what I mean?